hi i'm andrew from the youtube channel
follow andrew
so if you like this content you want to
see more design html css
web development type of stuff come on
over to my channel and
uh join me there there'll be a link down
in the description where you can
check out join me over my channel now in
this
series we're going to be covering
building a custom wordpress theme from
an existing html template
again the link for the template is down
in the description so you can follow
exactly along with the same steps i'm
doing
but this step in process should be able
to be applied to any existing html
template
so you can convert your own to your own
existing wordpress theme
so i've been developing on the web for i
don't know over 20 years i think i first
started using wordpress back in 2005 or
2006.
i've kind of been playing around and
using that ever since so i hope you
learned something don't forget to share
this content
and uh let's get started
all right in this tutorial we're going
to be converting this
design here into a custom wordpress
theme
now this design is a fully responsive
design and it is based off of bootstrap
and i'll just kind of show you how the
design here looks so you can see that
it is responsive maybe when i break down
to a mobile point we get the mobile
media query
we have the sidebar on the left
navigation we also have a few
pages that are particularly important to
blog style websites
for example we have a home page that has
a little featured slider here and a few
things like that
we have a post page this would be what
an individual blog post would look like
notice how on the bottom here there is
also a comment section with nested
comments and replies as well
and then we have what is known as a blog
page so this would just be like
a static page like an about or a contact
page or something like that
we have our blog archive page which
would list all of our blog posts in some
sort of archive fashion
with our next links as well and then we
have a contact
us page just to kind of simulate a
simple web form you can also
enter so again all the pages on here are
fully responsive
in this uh layout and we're going to be
converting this entire template into a
custom wordpress
theme now wordpress themes are really
nothing more
than a hierarchy of template parts
and what i mean by that is in this theme
right here i'm just going to divide this
into a couple little sections here
so this area here at the top right this
area
we would typically call like the page
heading or the title
and this area over here this entire
sidebar area we could call that a
sidebar we call it a heading
this area right in here is called a
navigation this
area over here we would call our
content area and then if we get clear
down to the bottom here
of our page almost scroll down a little
bit right here
this section right here right we could
call the comments
section and then at the very very end
down below
we would call our footer area right here
uh our footer right so this gray bar at
the bottom
so in other words all websites have kind
of some sections to them
and really all a wordpress template or
custom theme does is it takes all those
various sections
and splits them apart into individual
files
so it's sort of like creating components
from your
template so instead of having just one
big long html file
i have many many separate pieces one
with the header one with the content one
with the footer one with the sidebar one
with the menu
and then wordpress sort of puts all
those back together into a single
long file as needed so when we're
creating our
wordpress theme here to start we're
going to be doing a fairly basic theme
but it will have all the features of a
custom wordpress theme
and we're going to start out with the
required files that you need in order to
set up a wordpress theme
so again this tutorial assumes there's
some prerequisites here of course we're
not going to be designing this from
scratch i've done that in a previous
video this particular layout
and this assumes that you've already got
wordpress set up and installed
on your local server or on a live web
server somewhere
as you will need to have wordpress
installed and running in order to create
the custom theme
so assuming those two things are already
complete let's go ahead and
and complete this process now i will
make this particular theme
available in the description so that if
you want to follow on
exactly with my same template you can
but the process here really applies to
any sort of template that you're going
to be creating
so let's get started with the first
required template files
okay now i want to first show you the
structure of a wordpress theme and where
those files need to be uploaded
now here in this sidebar here i've got
my main
wordpress directory so this has all the
wordpress files that are installed when
you unpack and download the zip file
there's a folder in there called wp
content
and inside of the wp content there is a
folder called
themes and this is the folder in this
area where you will put
your specific theme so what you would do
here is you would create a folder so i'm
just going to create a new folder here
and i'm just going to call my theme
follow andrew and once we have our
folder in place
i've got this little directory here
that's called my theme template
so i'm going to drop that in this as
well as we're going to be referencing
those
html and css files quite often so to
make it easier i'm just going to drop
that template which has my just basic
html and css files that i just barely
demonstrated for the actual template
we'll be converting here
inside of this template folder okay so
once you have that in place you can go
ahead and open up your follow andrew
theme or your folder inside of your code
editor
so i'm going to switch over to vs code
that's the code editor that i'm going to
be using here
to set up my to do all the development
here in php
so the first thing we need to do is
create all of the folders and files that
are required
for a wordpress template so i'm just
going to go ahead and add those here in
my follow andrew theme folder
so the first one we're going to be
adding is called the assets folder
and the assets folder is going to have
several subfolders as well so i'll come
inside of my assets
and i will add the first one which is
going to be css and then i will add the
next one which is going to be our fonts
and then i will add the next one which
is going to be the images
and one more which is going to be the
javascript
okay so assets has all of those inside
of them of course we're going to be
placing our css
files and things like that in there in a
minute the next folder we're going to
create here in our main
directory is going to be our classes
so we'll just create that now this
folder is going to be used to create any
php
classes that we'll be using for various
functions to override wordpress
functionality
we're going to create another one here
called inc
so whoops i created that one in the
wrong spot
this uh needs to be outside there so inc
stands for includes and that's going to
be any sort of include files that we
want to also include
and we'll go ahead and create one more
here and this one is going to be
called template dash parts
so this is a common folder you'll see in
many wordpress themes
it just allows us to split little
individual parts of our template
up even further and again this is all
sort of
uh common but you can really split up
your template and theme however you want
there's no really set rules here and
then we're going to create one more
whoops i did the same thing here i need
to create this as a not as a subfolder
here
and another one called templates
so these are the required folders that
we have assets with all these subfolders
and then classes
inc template parts templates and and
then this is our
master template so again these aren't i
shouldn't say required but this is how
we're going to build our theme
now the next thing we're going to do is
set up several files so these files
there's actually only
two files that are required for a
wordpress theme the css file
and the index.php file those are the
only two that are required
everything above and beyond that is sort
of how you want to customize and do your
wordpress theme
so we'll go ahead and start off here and
we're just going to create all the blank
files we're not going to be adding any
content whatsoever at this point
so the first one here is going to be um
our 404.php this is the file that will
be served when we get a 404 server error
the next one is going to be a file
called archive.php
this file will be responsible for
delivering an archive
so a good example of this is like a blog
post the index of all the blog posts in
a hierarchical format
that would be an archive page the next
one here is going to be the comments.php
so this template file will be
responsible for displaying and serving
up comments
in our theme the next one here
is going to be one called footer.php
and this is going to be responsible for
the footer section right the very bottom
of your website
the next one here is going to be our
functions.p and this file has special
meaning in wordpress because
in your functions.php file is where you
can
override and initiate different features
of your theme inside of wordpress
so your functions.php file is going to
be raw php code
typically to override and change the way
wordpress works fundamentally
uh next we're going to go ahead and add
one called header.php
so this is going to be the the file
responsible for the top head section
that would be anything in the head
really whatever we determine we want to
put in there
the header uh the next file is going to
be our
index.php so here is the first required
file so you have to have one called
index.php
it serves as the fallback so if
wordpress can't locate a specific
template file in the template hierarchy
that it needs
it will always fall back to index.php
that's why it's required
the next one here is going to be called
page.php
this template file will be responsible
for displaying static pages so things
that aren't blog posts or aren't blog
archives
like an about page would be a static
page so that's the template file that
will do that
the next one here is going to be called
we'll just add a readme
dot text and this is just going to be a
text file where we can put like
copyright notices and things like that
if someone else were to download our
template
we can put some information in there in
a readme file
and then the next one here is going to
be called search.php
so this is the template file that will
display search results so when somebody
comes over to your wordpress site right
and they hit this search button up here
what's going to show up there the next
file here
is going to be our single dot php
and this file will be responsible for
responsible for displaying
single blog posts so when you click on
an individual blog post
that's how that template file or who
will display
and then the last file that we need is
going to be our style dot css
so again this is the second required
file you have to have a file called
style.css
this is the master style sheet for your
website
so over here on the right hand side you
can see that i've got
a wordpress site running locally this is
just the default 2020
wordpress theme that i have installed so
i'm just going to kind of show you here
so when i come over here and do a search
so i'll just search for hello and do a
search
you can see that i've got some results
that came back right
the results that are being returned are
going to be using this search.php
template so how this page looks will be
determined by the
code in that template if we come over
here to a blog archive so if i click on
like post from march 2020
it's going to give me all the posts for
march 2020
that would be using the archive.php
template
if i click into an individual post like
here's my hello world post so i'm going
to go ahead and click on that post
you can see i'm now looking at this
individual blog post
this one's going to be using the single
dot php template file
of course my comments down here at the
bottom are going to be using my
comments.php template file etc etc
right you kind of get the idea there so
these are all the required files
that we'll be using in this example but
again there's really only two that are
required from wordpress
so uh the last little thing i'm going to
add here to our
theme folder is a screenshot so a
screenshot is typically just a little
screenshot of what the theme looks like
if you were to put this on the wordpress
store it would show up you know when
you're searching for themes as a little
thumbnail of what that theme would look
like
so i'll go ahead and add that next okay
so i've gone ahead and just taken a
quick screenshot here so if i click on
screenshot you can see this is the
screenshot that i've added into the
site and that's how it looks so
let's go ahead and now look at one more
thing here and this is called the
template hierarchy
now we've just sort of determined to
build our hierarchy in a sort of
similar common fashion i would say for
wordpress themes
but i want to show you kind of a
detailed look at what's known as the
template hierarchy
so you can see here over here on the
right hand side it's a little easier to
read this from right to left i think
but the index.php file in wordpress is
the fallback template file
then there's one you can create called
singular so if your single blog posts
and your pages look the exact same you
can just create one called singular that
essentially will act for both
and there's one in here called archive
you can see and
archive will catch is the catch-all for
all archive pages
but if you want to get more specific you
can create one called category so each
one of your blog post
categories can have a different look and
feel or maybe you can sort them by date
you can see you just move from right to
left through this screen you can see
there's a million different
uh ways you can sort of create and
customize your wordpress themes based on
all of these different types of files
so the last file that we haven't added
yet that we will add
is this one right here called front page
so often times the main landing page of
a website
looks different from all the other pages
of a website so if you want to do that
you can do it two ways you can create
one called
home.php which will work for
both the blog posts and index pages and
also the static front page you can see
if you want to get more specific you can
create one called front dash
page dot php to use instead
so that's the last file we'll create
here but again that you can kind of
reference this
dialog to see all the various types of
template files you can create
for your wordpress theme so i'll jump
back here to my code
and we will create one final file in
here called
front dash page dot php and add that one
in there
okay so now let's make it so that we can
actually use this wordpress theme so
we're gonna come over here to our
style.css file
and add just a couple of elements in
here to the head section
so wordpress files have a style css
and at the very very top they have a
comment section
so it's just like you would do a normal
css comment like this
and then you're going to add various
things inside of here and wordpress will
use that to display when you go to
install it you'll see what i mean here
in a minute
but the first one we're going to add is
one called theme name
and i'm just going to call this uh my
follow android theme but again this is
whatever you want to call your theme
and the next thing here is going to be
our text domain
and i'm just going to call this follow
andrew as well the next thing in here
is going to be your version so i'm just
going to call this version 1.01
and then you can add a description of
your theme
so i'll just say a fancy wordpress
we'll call this a fancy left sidebar
theme
and then you can also add some tags so i
can call this
uh left dash sidebar
responsive fancy
and then i'm gonna go ahead and create
the author that's
andrew wilson and then you can do what's
known as an author
a you author uri so this would be
the url right if you have your own
website or something i'll just do http
colon slash youtube.com
follow andrew again you can place any
sort of url there i suppose we need http
s and there's a few other ones in here
as well for example you can add the
license type you can add
some other additional things again on
the wordpress codecs
you can see all the available things you
can add inside of this comment
but it's always the very first thing in
your css sheet it needs to start on line
one
so we add that in there and that's
pretty much all we need so i'm going to
go ahead and save that file
and now that i have that uh file with
all these required sort of metadata if
you will in your style sheet
i'm going to log in here to my wordpress
site in the backend
so i'll come down in here and i'll say
login and i've just got this set up with
a little
username and password for my
andrew andrew and this is the wordpress
backend
so now when i come over here to my
appearance and over to my
themes you'll notice that there is a new
theme here i'm going to pull this over
just a little bit
so you can see there's my new theme so
i've got the default theme installed
which is the 2020 theme that comes with
wordpress
and now i've got my follow andrew theme
so if i click on theme
details you can see all these details
over here in the right hand sidebar that
should that should make sense now right
so there's my theme name there's the
version
there's the author if i click on this
it'll take me to the link there is my
description here are all of my
tags that i added so all that
information is pulled directly from your
stylesheet
okay and then of course here is the
screenshot.png file so that's coming
from right here my screenshot.png file
and they might have a specific size i
didn't even double check that on
requirements here
i just sort of snapped one and uploaded
it but double check the codecs they
might have a requirement on the size for
this particular image but
it works as long as you have one called
screenshot.png
in your theme folder and that's pretty
much it so
once you have those required files you
should see your theme here up here
now i'm going to go ahead and activate
this theme so all you have to do is
click
activate and this will essentially make
my new theme become the active theme
so now i'm going to switch back to the
main front end
and you'll see that there's really
nothing here it's completely blank i
don't see any posts
and that's because all of my template
files are
completely blank right there's nothing
to them
so now we're going to start to actually
flesh out these wordpress
template files so the one we're going to
start with is the home page remember
that is what we set up on the one called
front dash page so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to come into this
template site file remember this is the
theme rather the template that we're
converting into a custom wordpress theme
this template is available in the
description for download if you want to
follow along with the exact code i'm
using
but of course these tips and tricks can
be used for any template so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to come into
the index.html page
and this page houses of course all of
the html
for this particular file so i'm just
going to literally copy and paste
everything here i'm going to highlight
everything command
a command c and then come over here to
my frontpage.php file
and paste and i'm just simply going to
save so i'm going to say command s and
save
now you'll notice that over here in the
right in the preview i did have some
things appear
so what i'm seeing now is some of the
content
and i'm actually seeing my bootstrap css
and html files being loaded
but i'm not seeing my custom css file
being loaded
and that is because if we look up here
in our heads section notice that we are
linking to bootstrap
let me just wrap these lines here so we
can see that a bit better
whoops we are linking to
bootstrap via the content delivery
network so this is a
hot link right we're linking to fontasam
via the cdn as well
but we're linking to our own css sheet
just with this relative file path
so this file path is incorrect because
we know that our style sheet
is now down here called style.css
and of course it's not in a css folder
anyway this path is all incorrect
now what we could do is we could
actually come in here and hard code the
path i could say path
to file and code that all in it would
actually work it would load up my file
properly
in fact i'm just going to show you that
just to prove the point here so i can
say dash
wp content uh
dash um let's see what i named this
theme
follow andrew slash
style.css now let's see if this is
correct here
and oops i forgot to add the
themes directory there there we go so
you can see if i hard code in the path
to this css sheet right here
it does work right i get my css sheet
and everything over here is working as
expected
i'm going to zoom out a click or two
just so we can see the full sidebar
and it's all working however it's not a
good idea to hard code in your css and
javascript paths like this
and the reason is is that if other
plugins that i install inside of
wordpress
depend on some of these files that i
have linked
wordpress doesn't know which order to
load them in
and you will see that problem when we do
this in a minute so it's a better idea
to do what's called in
queue the wordpress css or your own
theme
css and javascript files that way
wordpress itself can determine which one
to load first and which one to load
second
or if plugins require specific
javascript or css files or vice versa
so that's what we're going to do next
we're going to enqueue all these files
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to simply
we'll do this kind of in a one by one
fashion here so we're going to come over
to our functions.php file here
and this we're going to add our first
piece of code
so we're going to start off here with
just opening and closing some php tags
and then we're going to create a
function in here and the function name
really doesn't matter um but i like to
always kind of prefix my functions
with a name like follow andrew
that way my own functions names don't
clash with built-in
function names of wordpress by chance so
that's kind of a
good practice there and we're going to
call this one the register
styles because that's what this function
is going to do is register our styles
okay so the first we're going to do is
there's a function in wordpress called
wp-e-n-q-u-e-u-e-n-q
style and this takes a few parameters
here so the first parameter
is the name i'm just going to call this
the follow dash
andrew
we'll call it whoops i'm not going to do
a hyphen there i'll call it follow
andrew
i can type that correct dash bootstrap
so the first parameter is just a name
it's just whatever you want to name your
style sheet internally
the second parameter here is the actual
url to the style sheet
remember that is where i showed you
before where we could
hard code right this is the url however
this part right here
wordpress can figure out for us so if we
come back here
so i'm going to say comma here and there
is a
an option here called get template
directory uri
so this is a function that returns the
path up to your
current themes directory so that's what
we're going to use
and then we're going to concatenate here
with period and then we're just going to
add the slash
style.css okay i'm going to pull this
over just a little bit here
okay so that's the second parameter is
basically the path to your stylesheet
now the third parameter here i'm going
to do just as an empty array for now
and the fourth parameter here is a
version so i'm just going to say
1.0 now i'm hard coding the version in
right here right now but in a minute i'm
going to make that
dynamic so that it will automatically go
and look inside of my style sheet and
pull that version number we set up
earlier
to make that dynamic and then the last
parameter here
is optional but this is which style
sheet this is going to be for
so whether it's a print a projection all
right the different types of style
sheets
so i'm just going to leave that as all
for now
okay so that looks okay so that's what
i'm going to put inside of that function
and now i need to make this function
hook into wordpress's system
so that's where we're going to say add
action
and we're going to hook into the
uh the hook called the wp
and cue
scripts command and
you simply just copy and paste whoops i
spelled that kind of funny so i'm going
to fix that
register style you just copy and paste
your function name right there so what
this line is doing it says when
wordpress runs this hook
also execute my function so in other
words my function will execute at that
same time
so that's all we need to do there now
let's go ahead and save and it looks
like you can see i've got an
error here looks like on functions line
seven
so i don't have my line numbers turned
on
um but it's probably because i'm missing
a semicolon after this
yes i am missing a semicolon okay so we
save and
that looks like that's now working
properly
so now we need to test it out so in
order to test it we're going to come
back to the front page
and we're going to delete this
hard-coded style sheet and we're going
to replace it with a php command here
called wp underscore whoops wp
underscore head which stands for
wordpress head and what this means is
wordpress
is going to then inject all these files
by itself
so we've kind of replaced that now let's
actually see if it worked
so we're going to refresh i am still
seeing my style sheet so it looks like
it's working but just to double check we
can right click and say
view page source and now you can see
that there's actually
quite a few extra things in here that
did not used to be in my head section
for example this style this inline style
tag
there's this manifest edit uri generator
all this stuff wordpress injected into
my head
because it was coming from the wp head
command
and then most importantly we need to
make sure that we can actually see
our style sheet that we just barely
loaded and that one
is let's just do a little search for it
here
um there it is right there so
i called this the bootstrap css but i
actually linked to my own css it wasn't
me thinking but there it is you can see
that it definitely is injecting that
style sheet
we just barely loaded so now what we're
going to do is we're essentially going
to do the same thing for these other two
style sheets the font awesome and the
bootstrap style sheets
so i'm going to come over here back
let's kind of close this source code
down
yeah we just want to double check to
make sure the files that you think are
being loaded dynamically are in fact
being loaded dynamically
so let's come back here to our functions
file
and now we're going to essentially copy
this and we're going to paste it
two more times and then we'll just paste
all these in one by one
so the first thing we need to do is
change the name so i'll say bootstrap
then we'll say actually this one's going
to be my custom style so i'll call this
the
follow-under style the next one will be
bootstrap and the next one will be
font awesome okay
and then we need to replace them with
the paths now i'm not
using local versions of font awesome or
bootstrap of course
i'm using the cdn versions so i'm going
to
grab those urls so come over here to the
front page we'll start here with the
bootstrap one
so i'm going to copy this entire url for
the bootstrap
jump back to my functions and that's
going to be the second parameter here
so i'll delete all that and just paste
in that hard coded path to the bootstrap
version
and then we can do the same thing
excuse me for phantasm
so we'll grab fontasam we'll come back
here to our functions
and we will replace that second
parameter
with fontasam and save now we can come
over here to our front page and i can
now delete
all of this code because
it's now being dynamically loaded via
this command here
now here's that problem i mentioned
earlier so you can see that i refresh
but i actually got a different color
here
for my main navigation
and that is because the order of my
style sheets is loaded
incorrectly so if i come over here and
say view page source one more time let's
pull this open
you can see that first i'm loading my
custom style sheet
and notice that right there on the end
it says and ver equals 1.0 that's where
that version is coming from
then i'm loading bootstrap then i'm
loading fantasm
the problem is my style sheet is
dependent on bootstrap so bootstrap has
to load first
then my style sheet has to be loaded
second because my stylesheet is
overriding bootstrap's
css variables so i have to have that
source order correct
and that is where that second parameter
that we left as an empty array comes
into play
so let's come back here to our functions
and remember this empty array right here
what this empty array
is i'm going to line wrap here whoops i
keep hitting the wrong command for a
line wrap
whoops there we go it is an array of
dependencies
so for example i'm just going to put one
parameter in other words
my follow andrew style is dependent on
this bootstrap css file so i'm going to
copy the id or the name
and just paste it right in there to that
first parameter and
save and now you can see it turns back
purple so that's now correct so let's
again just go ahead and view the page
source here
and now you can see that it is loading
bootstrap first
then my css second and then the font
awesome
because we've added that dependency
parameter
okay back to our functions now i
mentioned we're going to do one more
thing with that version because right
now our version
is hard-coded right we've just hard
coded 1.0
um so for the bootstrap it's version
4.4.1 so maybe i'll just copy this and
paste that in there
and then for font awesome it's 5 13 0 so
i can paste that one in there
but for my version i want this to be
dynamic so what i can do is i can create
a variable called
version and i can set that equal to wp
there's a command in here called wp
theme i'm checking my notes here i don't
have all this memorized
um and then we say get
and then in here we can say version
okay so basically this wp theme get lets
us get any of those parameters we set up
in our style sheet
so this should assign our current
version which is declared in our style
sheet right here
as our property
as this variable so now i'm going to
take this variable and we're going to
replace this
1.0 with that variable and save
okay so now let's just double check and
make sure that worked so we can view the
page source
so we can come over here and look at our
style sheet right here
and it does say version 1.0 so now as i
update my theme or my style sheet
i can just simply come over to that
style sheet
so we'll come in here i'm going to
change this to like 1.5 and save
and then we're going to come over here
and we will refresh
and then just double check this let's
pull this over and now you can see sure
enough it says version 1.5
and that's because we've made that
parameter dynamic so that's how you can
kind of
work with that again the version
parameter is completely optional you
don't even have to have that
but it it kind of makes sense
especially if you're doing lots and lots
of updates to prevent browser cache
issues when you have that
uh version get parameter appended to the
end of the
the style sheet link okay
so that's pretty much it for our style
so we have all those styles registered
and they're now running and adding
properly
now we need to do the exact same thing
for
the scripts that are down in the footer
so for any javascript files
so to make this simple i'm basically
just going to copy this entire function
come down here a little bit and paste
now instead of saying register styles i
will change this one to register
scripts and i will change this one down
here to register
scripts and then we'll delete all this
in here
and then rinse and repeat so if we go
back to
our front page we can see that down in
the footer area
we have a bunch of javascript files so
i've got bootstraps javascript files
and then i've got my own javascript file
in here
as well so we're going to replace all
these just like we did before
so let's come over here to our
uh keep getting lost have too many tabs
open enter the functions file
and we will do the scripts next
okay so we're going to say
wp and q and it's very similar but
instead of style it's just called
script for this one and all the
parameters are basically the same
so let's follow andrew and we'll just
start off with
i don't know bootstrap or something
okay then for the second parameter um we
are hard
coding these so we're going to go get
not hard coding but we're linking to the
cdn version again for bootstrap
so i'll just grab it looks like first we
have jquery slim
so i'll copy that and we'll come back
here
and paste that in
and we're just going to leave an empty
array because it's not dependent on
anything
and our theme version we really don't
need
for this particular one i mean we could
add it right if we wanted to so we could
say
3.4.1 just like we did on the other ones
okay so let's save that now we're going
to come over here to our
footer and just like we did with the
header area
in our front page uh we need to i've got
to
get rid of some of these tabs here in
our front page we're going to replace
down here we're going to add that php
command just like we did in the header
but this one's going to be called
wp underscore
foot um like
so i actually think it's
footer yeah on the head it's wp head and
then down here it's wp
footer okay so and then we can delete
now this
javascript a jquery code
save and let's see if it works so now
we're going to view the page source
and we're going to come down here and
look at our footer and see if it
actually inserted that
jquery code so it
doesn't look like it's there i'm not
seeing the jquery so i must have typed
something wrong so let's go double check
and make sure we have that code
correctly in our functions file
tag is being dynamically loaded but it's
being loaded in the header section
where i actually want it down here in my
footer section
so to fix that that's actually the last
property i left out here on this wp and
skew
in q script command so the last
parameter
is either false or true and the default
is false if you set it to true that
means it's going to place it in the
footer so i'm going to save that there
and then let's go ahead and refresh here
and we should see
yep there it is so now that file you can
see
is appearing down in my footer perfect
okay so now all we need to do is let's
just copy and paste this
two three four times i think we need
four more files
so the next one we need is popper so
this is a javascript
um
file that is required so we're gonna put
this one right inside of here
actually let's do these in order i'm
going to do bootstrap
uh oh this is actually popular this is
what bootstrap requires so popper is a
library for bootstrap
so we'll pop this one in here i have no
pun intended
and call it popper we'll just keep
replacing these version numbers over
here
and then we're going to grab the
bootstrap
javascript file next it's going to go
right here and we'll just call this one
bootstrap and then the last one is our
own javascript file called
main.js so this is where we need to grab
this function again here
so we can come grab our get template
directory
let's delete this default one so get
template directory
dot and then our javascript files
remember are in our
assets folder and inside here we're
going to have
a javascript folder so they're going to
be inside of
slash
assets slash js
main.js and we're just going to call
this version
1.0 now i can do the same thing here
is i can prefix these as well i can get
the version number for my theme but i'm
just going to leave it hard-coded i kind
of explained that up there
and we'll save and refresh let's make
sure all those are
loading okay and it looks like they are
so now the last thing we need to do is
you will notice
that um my file
here whoops we need to go delete all
these out of here now so we can delete
all these so they're not
hard coded anymore and save and refresh
and now we can see sure enough there is
jquery
popper bootstrap and lastly my file
which you can see is not showing up and
that is because that file doesn't exist
in the directory i claimed
so we need to go place it there so we
need to go to my
uh template so i've got this inside of
my blog site template open up my
javascript file
i'm going to copy this file so copy and
then i'll come into my assets folder
and come into my javascript folder here
and we will paste
okay so we want that to be inside of the
javascript
which i don't think it is here let me
fix that
i can't believe i didn't realize this
before when i was creating all these
files
but you can see i've got assets and css
inside assets fonts is inside of css
images and inside of fonts so i've
actually messed up these directory
structures so i need to move them all
back out i don't know if you can drag
and drop um
let's see if it'll let me yeah that's
actually working so i've got to drag all
these back to the main assets folder
there we go and then drag this
javascript file inside of the js folder
which it's now there okay so now that's
in the proper place there
that's looking fine and let's save and
refresh and see if we're now getting
our own javascript file to load here
and i'm still not seeing that
so we've still got a path issue let's
just double check so we have assets then
javascript and main.js
let's come over here to our functions
file so we're coming into our template
directory
assets js main.js
loading in the footer oh whoops we have
a name conflict
i haven't updated this one so this one
is just uh we'll call this one main
that may be why it wasn't uh loading
and there we go so there's my file
there's the js file you can see it's
loading properly
yep so of course you can't use the same
name twice or you'll get conflicts so i
hadn't
updated that so there is all of my
scripts that are inside of the footer
so now we've successfully enqueued all
of the
style tags we've enqueued all of the
scripts tags loaded those in the footer
and now my site is essentially working
properly where wordpress is now managing
the loading
of those files so that's step
one is in queue the files now the next
step we need to do is actually set up
our literal header and footer files so
right now inside of our uh
our front page right we just have we
have wp head
but then we have all this extra stuff
that's just hard
coded inside of our template and we want
to further remove that into a separate
header.php file and
footer.php file so this is kind of up to
you on how you
want to end up determining what content
goes in your head and what time content
goes in your foot
but what i'm going to determine is that
everything including the navigation
up to the main content here in the page
title will be in my head
and then everything down here will be in
my footer but you can split this up
again however you really want
so for me i'm just going to double check
and look at the code here so i want
all of this stuff all the way down until
i get to this main title here which is
all the way down to right there my
closing
header html tag all this stuff i'm going
to cut
so i'm actually not going to actually
i'm going to cut right here because i'm
in my php file so command x to cut
and let's come over to the header.php
file and
paste so i'm going to save that all
there now let's come back and do the
same thing for the footer
so essentially i'm going to come down
and where this closing footer ends
i want uh let's see what i want in my
footer probably everything
main wrap includes that copyright notice
so basically for my footer i'm just
going to cut out this right here
and we will cut that we'll leave this
main wrap
that houses everything alone and we'll
place all of that stuff inside of my
footer okay so we'll save that
and that looks fine there i'm just going
to tidy that up while i'm here
okay now since we've cut those two
pieces out we need to dynamically load
them back
and wordpress has a function for that so
i'm going to open up my php tags here
and it is called get underscore header
so you can see as soon as i type that in
and save sure enough my header comes
back into place let me comment that out
so you can see that
notice that without the header i'm just
getting my content
so if i view page source there's right
there's nothing above and below it
so that looks fine there and it looks
like i actually have an issue with my
html i'll have to correct that later i'm
missing a
opening or closing div somewhere uh but
so what we can do is we can replace that
with
get header and that will bring in my
header and then down at the bottom
i can open and close some php here and
same thing i'm going to say
git footer so this is very simply
this is very similar to just native php
where you say
include right all it's doing is just
including that file and including that
file
but in the wordpress way of doing that
so now when i refresh you can see sure
enough i've got my header i've got my
footer
everything's getting put back together
here on this main
page and that looks fine so the next
issue we need to fix
is we have our header and our footer
loaded dynamically we've enqueued all of
our scripts and all of our css files
now we need to change some things that
are
dynamic like our page title for example
if we come into our header
notice that the title tag is hard coded
that's going to be a problem of course i
want this to be dynamic based on
whatever page i'm currently on inside of
wordpress
so that's what we're going to fix next
is we're going to fix this little title
tag
two ways you can do title tags you can
manage
them yourself meaning you hard code the
title into the actual
head section and then you replace this
with a little command that's called like
get the title
which is a wordpress specific feature so
that's method one
method two is you just completely remove
the title tag all together from your
head section
and you let wordpress dynamically add
that title by itself
that's the method i'm going to opt for
for this video so to do that we need to
come to our functions.php file
and i'm going to add here above here
just up here on line one there's a
command or a function rather that's
called
add theme support so add theme support
and then title tag like so
so what this is basically saying i'll
just do this in a comment here
but this adds dynamic
title tag support so in other words
wordpress is going to then manage the
title tags
itself and it does that automatically as
long as we have in our header.php file
this wp head command so that's another
one of those
reasons why we have this so now when i
come over here and refresh whoops
and let's go ahead and look at the page
source you will see up here
that in the head section right now if we
scroll down here and look so i'm going
to search for that
title notice there is no
title tag at all right now on this
page and that's because wordpress hasn't
yet figured this out
so the reason wordpress hasn't figured
out to add this title tag dynamically
is because i forgot to wrap this in a
function so
i'm going to call this the function
follow andrew
we'll just call this theme support
so this is going to be a function i'll
go ahead and cut this and paste it in
here
and then i need to add this into a hook
as well
so the hook name here i'm just checking
my notes is
we're going to do another add action
and it's going to be after theme
setup is when this one will be called
and we'll just copy and paste this into
there
okay the issue i've just discovered is i
actually spelled title tag right typed
it in correctly it's not title
underscore tag it's titled
dash tag that's the one you want to add
in add theme support
so let's save that and refresh and there
we go now you can see my title appears
right here
it says blog site just another wordpress
site and that's
automatically being added into my page
via wordpress
so that's how we're going to leave that
managed now this title and description
is course is coming
currently from the settings inside of
wordpress so if you come into your
settings
general there's my title and there's my
tagline
so that's where those are getting
injected from but we can let that be
managed
by wordpress automatically and it will
inject in the proper titles according to
whether it's a post or a page and
whatnot
we'll look at that a little bit later
okay so back here
into our code we will
continue along so now we have our theme
support for our title tag we're
dynamically adding that we've got our
things enqueued and the next thing we're
going to do is add a few more options
here inside of our theme
to add some extra support so for example
for our specific site
here when we're on a post page i'm way
zoomed out here so you can see this so
i'm going to zoom back in
but we're on like an individual post
whoops i can't come to a post yet
but i have a specific width here i'm
just going to measure this quickly here
so you can see the width of my page is
roughly i don't know 800 or 900 pixels
so when i upload images that i want to
feature
inside of my posts or pages i really
don't want them
wider than that dimension because
they're never going to be shown larger
than that
so i can add what's known as custom
thumbnail sizes
so that anytime i'm inside of wordpress
i'll switch over here to the backend of
wordpress
when you go to the media gallery
and you say add new file and you drag
and drop files in here
wordpress automatically resizes those
and it uses the sizes that are set up
inside of your settings
so if you come to settings and then go
to media you'll notice that it has a
thumbnail size a medium size and a large
size
so if you want to customize sizes beyond
these three of course you can just
change them here you need to do that
inside of your theme
with your with the function in the ad
sizes
now a thumbnail medium and large is fine
for my needs so i'm just going to make
sure
this large value is roughly that width
and that actually works out fine 10 24
but just be aware if you want to add
extra sizes that's when you need to go
into your theme
and add support for custom thumbnail
sizes
okay so we've got our header we have our
footer we have our
functions.php file which is making that
title dynamic
and that's about as far as we're going
to get for this little section i just
want to mention what we're going to be
creating
here in the next video so in our
frontpage.php file we still have all of
our content right all this stuff right
here in the middle is hard
coded we did with div tags and content
right
we don't want that we want all of the
content to be managed by the wordpress
blog that's the entire point of
of creating a cms system is that you can
manage the content within wordpress
so what we're going to do is we're going
to end up deleting all of the content
out of this page we'll change our theme
a little bit to maybe put this header
and some of these footer tags down here
inside of our header and footer
and then we're going to talk about the
wordpress loop which is how we can tell
wordpress to query the database
pull out all of the content for the
specific page and insert it dynamically
into our loop or our section of content
so we're going to be starting here with
the front page and then we'll move and
do all of these separate template files
one by one by one
so you can see how that works and we
need to take all of this hard-coded
content that we added into our
front page and put that inside of
wordpress
so what i'm going to do here is i'm just
going to go into wordpress here so i'm
going to log into the back end of
wordpress
go to my pages section and say add new
and i'm just going to call this page my
home suite home
and i'll just type in something for now
so eventually i'll fix this up
i'm just going to go ahead and publish
that so it is now published
now i can come into my settings and
reading and i want my home page to
display
a static page and that page is my home
suite home
so we need to first create the page and
then we can tell wordpress to use that
page as my
as my website's homepage or front page
and then we're gonna hit save changes
okay
so now we can come over here and
we can go ahead and refresh this page
inside of our blog and you'll see that
right nothing's changing at this point
we still have all of the hard-coded
content
so what i'm going to do next is i'm
going to delete all this hard-coded
content
so i'm going to delete everything let's
see everything in this container i'm
just going to remove
so that container goes down to right
there
and so now we just have the article and
then we have our footer and our header
so that's looking pretty good now the
other thing i'm going to do
is for each specific page i just want to
have basically this
article tag so i'm actually going to
take this content right here
and cut that out and put that in my
header.php file
so that's going to go right below here
and then i will take let's go back here
to the front page
i'll take all this footer stuff down to
that closing div tag
save and i'm going to put that in my
footer.php file
right down there
actually i'm going to have this go right
above the wp footer command right there
okay perfect so now inside of my
template file essentially my header has
everything except the article the main
content which is the way i want it
so let's just type something here and
hit save and you can see sure enough
that appears
but i want the content that i saved in
that page to appear here
and this is where we're going to finally
talk about what's known as the wordpress
loop so wordpress a loop is basically an
iterator right which iterates over
several things
so when we save a page or a post or
really anything inside a wordpress when
we save something inside of our posts or
pages
that gets saved as a role in our mysql
database in my case
so what wordpress does is it dynamically
queries the database
finds which row corresponds to the page
you're on pulls that information
and displays it in that section and
that's known as
the loop so when i come over here we
need to create the loop code
so this is a little bit weird the way
they do this but wordpress uses
a while loop so what you can say is
um if we
have posts
okay so if posts exist basically
then we're going to execute this code in
here
so the next section is going to be while
and then we're going to say have posts
while we have posts we come down here
and we say the
post okay so let's save that
just far so if we have posts
and this is the iterator this is the for
loop or the while loop in this case
while there's posts whoops this needs to
be a function
while we have posts so this
in other words the post is going to
execute every single time as long as
there's posts
so we can save that and it looks like oh
yeah so that hadn't updated yet so let's
refresh that over here
looks like my web server actually may
have crashed you can see it's
trying and trying to reload this page
uh but i think it crashed so i may need
to restart my web server
i'm going to pause really quick and
restart the server okay
so i've restarted my web server and
we're back live here
so what we can do is we can call the
post and that essentially makes
wordpress query the database
and fetch out a single post once we've
called the post we can then call a bunch
of other wordpress functions
so i'm just going to show you one here
called the
content and this is one that actually
grabs the content and then starts it so
you can see as soon as i save that sure
enough my page now says
something so this content of course is
coming
from my page here let me go down to my
pages
it's coming from this page right here
right where it says
something so instead of saying something
i want
this to actually show right i guess
whatever is on my home page it really
doesn't matter at this point
but i'm just going to call this home
page content
and we'll go ahead and say update come
back here and
refresh and you can see sure enough
that's coming in
now i want this heading here to show me
the
title of the current page now because
that
is back here in my header
dot php file there's a command in here
that's called
uh i'll actually have to look this one
up really quick it's called i think get
the title
okay so the command is just called the
title
so i'm gonna come in here to this
heading and i'll just replace this
and say the title like so and then close
off the php and save
and now you can see it shows the current
page title or post title whatever it
would be
up there in that section right there and
then my content
is right down there so that's looking
great so that's really all we need right
now
for our front page to be mostly complete
so we have this little loop we're
pulling out the post and the content
and there's a there's several other
things you can pull out you can pull out
the author the date the time the tags
the post excerpt the post thumbnail post
images right
all those things are available inside of
wordpress commands and that's going to
really depend on how your theme set up
where you want to display certain things
but we'll get a little bit more into
that as we do these other template files
for our page in post
sections so we're going to save that and
now let's move on to another page so
one of the problems that we have is our
menu items right here inside of our
sidebar
are also hard coded so right
this is this is not going anywhere so i
need to make this
section dynamic and in order to do that
i have to add another thing to my
functions.php file which
enables uh menus wordpress
menus so let's go ahead and do that next
so we'll come in here to our functions
let me pull this down
and we will add our menu options
inside of our functions.php file we're
going to create a new function here
and this is just going to be called the
follow andrew and we're just going to
call the menus
okay now there is a in order to set up
your menus in wordpress you can set up
as many what are known as menu locations
so for example in my website i've got a
menu location over here on the left
perhaps i want another one on this
footer maybe i want a different menu
location for the
mobile right so you can set up different
menu locations
but for us we're just going to set up
two to show you how this works
so let's come over here and i'll pull
this over again so we're gonna create an
array so i'm just gonna call this one
the locations and i'll set that equal to
an empty
array for now and then inside of this
array it's basically key values so the
key is the menu location name
and the value is like the title and a
few things like that
so the first thing i'm going to do is
just call this one my primary menu
and the primary menu is
going to be we can just call this the
desktop primary
left sidebar right this is kind of a
description of your menu really whatever
you want to call that
and then i'll add one more and i'll call
this one my footer menu
and then i'll just say the footer menu
items
however you want to call that okay so
once you have your
your option declared your function we of
course need to add in another hook
so we're going to say add actually sorry
i'm getting ahead of myself
there's one other command we need to do
inside of here and that's called
register nav menus
and we need to pass in this variable so
this is an array of all of our nav menu
names and descriptions okay so all that
code is inside of our function
then we need to add in to the action so
we're going to add
add action this one's going to be inside
of the
init hook so we'll copy and paste in our
function name like we've done several
times before
so this function is going to hook into
the initialize function which happens
fairly early on in the
in the hook process and we'll go ahead
and save
okay now that we have those active if i
come back and log into wordpress here
and now go into my appearance
and notice that before i didn't have an
option for menus menus actually was not
even in this menu
but now because i've added that in my
theme i can click on the menus
and i now have menus available to me
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create our first menu so i'm just
going to call this menu name
the main menu and we'll say
create and now notice right here i have
these
two locations i have my desktop primary
and my footer
so now i can select where i want this
menu to appear inside of my theme
so let's go ahead and i'm just going to
add a couple of
options here so for right now i'm just
going to create
a few new pages so i'll come into my
pages and hit add new
i'll call this one my about page the
only reason i'm doing this
is just so i have something in my menu
in order to show right now
so we'll publish this let's add
we will add one more and we'll call it
contact us
and we'll say contact and we'll publish
that page as well
okay so now when i come back in here to
my appearance menus
i have a few things over here i can add
so i'm going to add all of these three
the default sample and then those two
and i'm going to say add to menu
and you can see that they get added
right here to my main menu in wordpress
you can drag these as
sub menus and they'll appear as drop
down menus if your theme supports that
or just as main items like this
and now i want to say i want this menu
to appear in my
desktop primary left sidebar
so i'll go ahead and click on my save
menu
okay so now this menu is created in
wordpress it's set to be displayed
where that menu location is but i of
course haven't actually
added the code for that menu to appear
so that's where we'll jump back into our
code editor
and we're now going to go set up what's
known as the primary menu
so that is done if we recall back in our
theme we come into our header
our header has that entire menu it's a
little bit tricky here i'm going to
line wrap this but this is all the code
for that menu that's hard coded so
essentially i want to remove all that
hard coded menu
and replace it with a wordpress function
that's going to automatically
dynamically display the menu
so let's do that next now you can see
here from my
code my menu is inside of this unordered
list
so i have a div called navigation and uh
this
is these classes collapse navbar
collapse flex column
these are wordpress sorry not wordpress
these are bootstrap classes that
automatically enables the mobile
menu and automatically does a few things
like that but the actual menu itself is
all inside of the unordered list
each menu item right in my list here
is a simple unordered list with a list
item with a whole bunch of classes and
things that kind of make it
styled correctly so essentially what i
want to do is
i'm going to add some of my
own code right inside of this section
now eventually i'll delete
all of this hard-coded stuff but i'm
going to leave it right now because i'm
going to need to reference it as i build
this menu via wordpress
so the command you need is called um
wp nav menu and
with this function it takes several
parameters so we i'm going to open up
the function here i'm going to do these
parameters on one line
so it takes an array and i'm going to
put each of these parameters in the
array like this
okay so this function takes an array and
the array is a set of all the different
parameters
so the first one we're going to do is
just called menu and this
is the name of the menu you're trying to
output in my case the primary menu
menu remember how we registered primary
and footer so i'm going to output the
primary one right here
okay so that's the first thing the
second thing is just i'm going to say
container and i'm going to leave this as
empty for now i'm just listing it here
so you can see a few of the option
and then i'm going to say theme location
is primary
as well okay so this means right when
the user selected that theme location
i'm saying this is the primary location
right here and the
uh name should be fine right there okay
so now you can see if i if i open this
back up
i'm getting two menus right so now i'm
getting my contact my about and my
sample page
so let's go ahead and inspect these in
our
code over here and you can see
that it's a little bit messy here i'll
try to pull this out
but wordpress is injecting all sorts of
classes into this
menu so you can see that wordpress added
an unordered list
it gave that guy an id it gave it a
class of menu
each of the menu items has a class of
menu item then the post type and then
the object
page item 14 item 15 item 16.
so there's all sorts of stuff that
wordpress injects into the menu and you
can customize all this
as needed but it gets a little bit
tricky if you want to do advanced
customization because you have to
include what's known as a walker class
to be able to iterate over the menu to
customize everything
so we're not going to get that advanced
but we will learn a few of the tools to
where we can customize some of these
some of these classes so the next item
we're going to be adding here
is one that's called items wrap
and this declares it's sort of the
template
that is for the unordered list this is
what the items wrap
means so what you have to do here is you
have to
this is a little bit goofy because you
have to say ul
so i'm just going to open the ul and
close the ul so in other words i'm going
to wrap this with an unordered list
and then i have to put parameters inside
of here where wordpress will
individually
add my classes so one thing is going to
be id
the other thing is going to be a class
and then inside of the unordered list i
have to put the
uh ampersand
three dollar sign s
and then when i save and refresh here
whoops looks like i missed a semicolon
or something
oh yeah i wasn't supposed to add a
semicolon right there let's go ahead and
save that
so now if i pull this menu back i'm
going to
go down one more time here i'm trying to
get this mobile menu whoops
to disappear there we go let's get that
text back up here and we'll inspect the
element again
and you can see here that now
my unordered list has an empty id and an
empty class whereas before it had all
that wordpress injected stuff
so now i can specify whatever id and
whatever class i want so my own
unordered list in my menu doesn't have
an id but i do have all these classes so
i'll just copy those and
paste that right into there and save and
then let's go ahead and
see what that looks like now perfect so
you can see now it's got the class and
it has
all those different classes in there so
that takes care of the items wrapper the
unordered list
but as i mentioned there's not an option
in here to
also affect the classes on the list item
with this wp nav menu in order to do
that we have to create this big long
custom walker and it's quite complex so
what we have to do in order to get
our classes on our list items is we
actually have to do that back inside of
wordpress admin
so let's come back in here and you can
see that if i open
up one of these options here for all of
these different
items so here i have my contact us
there's a few options in here that i can
toggle
so what we need to do is
we need to turn on an option here
screen options i believe there we go so
here it says show advanced menu
properties
we need to turn on the css classes
okay and the link target let's just turn
let's
well actually we don't need that one
that should be fine
okay now you can see that i can provide
a css class for the specific
option so again the class name i need
for me is the nav item right there
so i'm going to copy nav item and we'll
come over here and we'll click
paste and now let's go ahead and save
that
so we're just going to do this on one
for now but you can see that my contact
has the
nav item on it so let's go back here and
refresh
and see if we can now see that appear
here
so that is the first one right here
and sure enough you can see that it
still has all the wordpress classes over
here but it does have now the class of
nav item which is the one i was after
okay so that's looking good um for now
and we can go ahead and add that to the
rest of these
so we'll go ahead and add that to this
one and we'll add it
to this one and go ahead and
save so now all of those have that
and refresh okay so that's looking
better
now you can also see that in our menu
our
anchor tags themselves have the class of
nav link and there's no way for me to
customize the anchor tag with css
classes
so even if i come in here to wordpress
and i you know
toggle these guys this class is applied
to the unordered list
not the actual anchor tag and i'm
unaware of a way where you can do that
so you actually have to use a custom
walker
to make that happen we're not going to
get that far in this tutorial but
just be aware there's several other
tutorials out there on doing some
advanced things with walkers
but we'll just leave this with our nav
item now notice we also
have a inside of our anchor tag we have
this
icon so i'm going to copy the icon here
and i'll just copy this and let's
actually do this one
for the we'll do the blog post one just
to show you i'm not going to do this to
them all
but i'll copy this icon this is coming
over from font awesome
so what i could do if i wanted the icon
let's say on this
i don't know we'll just pick the about
page here i could
paste that directly that html directly
into the navigation
label and save and now when i come over
here and refresh
uh you can see that let me
zoom in here i've got my icon right so
there's the little icon appearing so
that's how you have to do your bootstrap
icons again it's a little bit clunky
doing it this way and that's because we
have a really specific markup that's
required because of bootstrap
a much easier way would be to change
your own css
and match wordpress's outputted
css classes that they give you um
but of course if you can't do that then
really you have to jump to that advanced
method with the custom
walkers in uh
inside a wordpress perhaps i'll do a
video on that in the future but
for right now we'll just leave it alone
like this okay so we've got these little
items
just so you can see the only thing
really this nav link is doing for us
if i inspect the element here and i just
manually add one so i'll come in here to
this code
and we'll say we'll give it a class
equals nav dash
link just so you can see all it's doing
is just changing the size
and the color of that
so perhaps what i can do to to get that
to work
is instead of calling these things nav
link remember wordpress
um gives these guys hey what does
wordpress do i actually don't know
um looks like they're actually not
giving the
anchor tags any markup at all so i'd
have to go into my own css and edit that
class and maybe perhaps move it up to
the nav item
so i could do something like let's come
over to my css
so we'll search for the nav dash item
and you can see that the nav item has a
little rule here that's
for the nav link so instead of calling
this nav link i'm just going to call it
anchor because that's really what it is
it's an anchor tag
and i'll call this one here anchor and
save and now they're basically
you know having that same same thing
happening to them oh here's another one
over here i guess i should just replace
all these nav links let's do a quick
search here
looks like i have five of them so this
one will be
anchor this one will be anchor
there's another one we're going to have
as anchor
well they're all over the place and all
these so i'll replace that one with
anchor this one with
anchor oops that's
oh that's nav link pre that's a
different one oh that's a different one
too
so that'll be anchor
now let's see if that's working so
that's a little bit better right so now
we're getting close there to
our previous menu down here it looks
like we have some issue with this
spacing
which i'm not sure where it's coming
from
looks like we have one more nav link
nope that's the previous
so i don't know there's a margin
somewhere in here i missed but we'll
just kind of ignore that
but you can see how that's going to work
so now that i've got those in there
and hard coded i can come into my header
and i can finally then take this old
menu and delete it out
because now that's been replaced by this
menu
so that was perhaps the most complex
thing we've done thus far and that's the
way the menus typically
tends to be because there's just lots of
nesting and classes all over to kind of
build those menus
so now we have our menu working there's
our three
little pages we have inside of there and
they're showing up just fine on
both the desktop and the mobile view as
they should
okay so that's how you build menus now
the next
thing we need to do now that we have our
menu out of the way
is create or our menus at least dynamic
is create uh the rest of our template
pages
so we can leave all these hard-coded all
the social links would just be
hard-coded likely anyway
and that's looking fine now for our
header the one thing i'm noticing right
here we might as well fix while we're
here
is that you can see my shortcut icon has
the incorrect
path so i want to just update this so
i'm just going to hard code this one wp
content slash themes slash follow
andrew slash assets
images logo.png i think that's where
that is so if we come into our images
that's where it will be so i'll come in
here and drop it in
so i'm going to come over here to my
template
uh i can't really see where i'm looking
at here
oh there he is blog site template images
there's my logo png i'll drop that
into my images folder
that's the little logo that's also going
to appear right up there right
okay so that would be like the favicon
is basically what this guy is the
shortcut icon
okay so that's looking fine there and
now let's go ahead and move along
so we need to now finish our
removing all the stuff that's hard coded
so for example we have our site name
that's hard coded right here into our
site name we have our logo that logo is
hard coded
in here as well so we need to start to
uh remove all that stuff
so we're going to start here with our
uh site name and logo so we're going to
show you how you can add a custom logo
meaning the user can go into the
wordpress admin
upload a logo and it'll automatically
then appear in your theme
so let's go ahead and do that so in my
navigation area is where i have
that logo stored
so the first thing we need to do is come
to our functions and just like we've
done many times before we need to add
the
theme support uh for this
function so remember we have this
function up here where we're gonna be
adding all of our theme support
so we're gonna say add theme
support and this one is going to just be
called
custom dash logo
okay so we do that now what that allows
if we jump over here now to
our back end and we come over here to
our
themes and we choose the customize
action on the installed theme
so you can see i can come in here to the
site identity and there's a new option
in here called
logo so i can click on select logo and
you can just come in here and browse to
the logo
i'll just select this logo that i've got
and say open
and this of course uploads it you can
give an alt text i'll just call this my
logo
and say select of course you can come in
here and do some cropping options i'm
just going to say skip cropping
and there is the logo so now that i have
a logo
i'm going to go ahead and click the
publish here
and come back and now that the logo is
in place i can actually
output it so let's come back here
and i'm going to come back to the code
here i'm
going to jump back over here to my
header.php file
come down to where i have this logo hard
coded
and then i can actually output it right
here
so the code you need to
output the logo is
i forget it i've got to look up my note
it is
we can do this one in an if function so
we can say if
function exists so this is just checking
to make sure
that the the custom
logo whoops
function exists because if we're on an
older version of wordpress or something
this may not work
so if that function exists then we say
the
custom logo and we just output it like
so
so now let's go ahead and refresh this
whoops
i wrote all that and i forgot to do my
php tags
make sure you actually
write that inside of php tags
and save and now you can see sure enough
there is my logo and it's automatically
output now you can see that the issue
here is that the logo gets output but
wordpress is adding again all of these
extra classes and all these things and
they don't
follow with what i need which if we come
back here to our
header file is
scroll down here whoops where'd it be
there we go so i need these classes
right because those are the classes that
i'm using on my logo
so what i need to do instead of saying
the custom logo i need to output
a little bit more so what we're going to
do is
we're going to say instead
we're going to say custom logo
id and this code i'm getting is just
from the the codex
so i'm going to say get theme
modification
custom logo
okay so i'm getting this variable and
then i'm going to say the logo is
equal to and then we say wp
underscore get attachment
image this is a little bit weird here
source
and then we pass in this custom logo id
right here
so whoops we need to make that a
variable so we pass in that variable
and that should do it
whoops i think i forgot a semicolon yes
i did so semicolon
okay so now you can see that
oh i still have an error in there
somewhere
um call to undefined function wp get
attachment source
so i must have spelled this wrong wp
get attachment image
source
yep i forgot an e there we go whoops
see attach mint there we go
okay that's correct now okay so
now if we just now this logo basically
has all the information about the
the image source so now what i can do is
i can just manually
output my image so
right here where it says source i'll
just delete that
and i'll replace that with the source
which comes from
our variable right here so i copy that
replace that inside of there
and save and refresh and that
still didn't output
i think i have short tags on but i'll
just do this the old way
php echo
and let's i'm still not seeing the logo
so let's just really quick do a quick
print
r on this to see what's inside of this
variable make sure it has the
information i'm looking for
so you can see it does have it so there
is the actual
image source oh it's the first it is a
multi-dimensional array and there's the
width and the height
um so what we need to do is we need to
get
the uh first parameter so we can say
logo sub zero
here we go and there my logo now shows
up okay so let's close that down and
save
so that was kind of a little bit of a
work but now you can see i can output
the custom logo there
and uh including my custom classes so
there's kind of two ways you can do that
right
if you want to do it the easy way you
just you know output that
simple function right there the custom
logo if you need to have it
customized and just need the path you
can grab the path using this code right
there
and then add that path directly into
your image tag as needed
okay so that is now i think mostly
done so let's close this down and just
double check so everything now should be
dynamic so our
oh we have to do that one last thing so
our logos dynamic our menus dynamic
the page content is dynamic the page
heading here is dynamic
our page title is dynamic so everything
is now being pulled from wordpress with
the exception of a couple of things and
that's our site name
of course we have this hard-coded we're
going to end up doing that in widgets in
the future tutorials so you can add
widgets in our footer to be able to
customize those text
boxes but let's go ahead and grab the
site name
and add that to that area right here
so to do that we'll just delete this
right here and we'll replace
that with a php call and it's going to
be called
get blog info
and then this is going to be the name
whatever the name attribute is of the
blog will output that for the site
title so uh that should be it
and we need to echo that there we go
and now it says blog site right so
that's basically whatever
is the name of the site so that's
customizable as well back in here right
this this
right here so i can call it uh andrew's
site or
we'll call it follow andrew follow
andrew
if i can type that correctly and just go
ahead and save and publish that
and now if we jump back here and refresh
right now that's dynamic as well
so we have our site name being pulled we
have our logo being pulled dynamically
with custom logo uploadability all of
our menu is dynamic
and that is now pretty much there so
what we're going to do
is start off by adding some posts into
our wordpress theme
so you recall we added these three pages
but we need to add now a whole bunch of
posts so we can mock up our
post page and our post archive page so
let's go ahead and do that next
the wordpress backend i'm over here on
the post tab and i'm just going to say
add new here for all these posts
so i'll just call this sample title 1
and we're going to be doing i don't know
10 or 15 of these so i'll just do one or
two
and then i'll pause the video do the
rest and you can go ahead and do that on
your own
so with the paragraph of text what we're
going to do here is we're going to do
two things we're going to have a
paragraph of text
and then go ahead and add in a couple of
tags
so i'll just say sample tag another
cool so we're adding in a few tags and
i'm also going to add in this
to my uncategorized category i'm going
to add in an excerpt so this is the post
excerpt an excerpt of course is optional
it's just sort of like a short
description of what this post is about
and then what we're going to do is go
ahead and say publish
and say publish okay so you can see it's
giving me this
sample link here for my post but the one
extra thing we need to add in here
is what are known as post thumbnails so
if i come over here to my posts
page and you see my sample post if i go
ahead and edit this
notice over here in the sidebar in my
document
there isn't any way for me to add an
image so a featured image to this post
and we want to be able to add that to
our theme because our mock-up calls for
those little featured images
so we need to go add that in our
functions file to add support for post
thumbnails so let's move back over here
to our code
in vs code and we're going to move over
to our functions file
and come up here to our section where
we're adding all of our theme support
and we're going to be adding the last
one right here
so let's go ahead and add another one
here we're going to say add
theme support and this one is just post
dash thumbnails like so
and we'll go ahead and save that and now
when we jump back over to the back end
and refresh here
you'll see that there's a new section
right over here
called featured image so what that
allows me to do is now i can come in
here and set a featured image
so i can choose from any existing image
that's already uploaded into the system
or i can click my upload files and just
go ahead and upload a new one so i'm
just going to upload a new file here
and we'll come over here because i've
got all these thumbnails already in
place
so i'll just choose this and hit ok so
i'll open this you can see it uploads
that i can give it an alt text
a sample image etc etc and then say set
featured image
you'll notice down here it sets that as
the featured image
now the featured image size or the width
and height of that you can customize in
your functions.php file
but remember by default that is set i'm
going to update this post really quick
before i move off of this page
you can update that in the settings
reading section
just kidding settings media section and
it's right here the thumbnail
size width and height so mine are going
to be resizing to 150x150
so now we can go back to that post and
if we view the post
you can see that it takes us to a blank
page and that's because
on our template file we don't have
anything yet set up for a post so that's
where we're going to start off with our
next template
is an individual post page so let's go
ahead
and jump back here to visual studio code
and
we're going to move over and start that
process
so let's come in here to or i'm going to
open up my sidebar again
and we will open up this time we're
going to come over here to
our front page we're just going to copy
everything so command a command c
because most of our template files will
be very similar and we'll move over here
to the one
called single dot php so the single dot
php is responsible for single posts
and i'm going to go ahead and just paste
and
save and now let's go ahead and navigate
back to that post i actually can't
remember the post id
um so let's go ahead and look here so i
can get over in the other document
um it is i guess i need to go back here
i'm just going to click on uh edit here
so i can see what the permalink is
preview there we go so it is post
22.
i guess i have to switch out of full
screen mode to see the bar here
okay so it is
p22 so i'll just copy that let's move
back over here to vs code
i'm just doing this because i don't have
a way to link to it quite yet we haven't
built that functionality yet
okay so this should give me that post
there we go
so you can see now i'm on the sample
title one there's my paragraph and my
text
and that's pretty much it that's all we
technically need to do
is just simply have a the
exact same content in the single dot php
so what we can do however is we can then
split up our posts
our single dot php posts into different
types
so for example i may have a post that's
a
gallery just pure images or i may have a
post that
is a full entire article or i may have a
post
that is a video so there's different
types of posts
inside of wordpress and we can split
those different template parts up
into know into what are known as
template parts and that's why we created
a long time ago
we created this folder called template
dash parts
so that's how we're going to be make
this single dot php template file behave
is it's going to search for a specific
template part that matches the post
type let's say so let's go ahead and set
that up
so instead of just saying output the
content
of the post this is the spot we're gonna
try to customize
so we're gonna cut that out and instead
we're gonna replace that
with a wordpress function called get
template i think it's just part yeah get
template part
and then we're going to look inside of
the this is the url so our folder is
called
template parts slash
and then whatever the content so we'll
just say content right here
just like so so the way this function
works is the first parameter
is the file path the second parameter if
i have
comma and then i have another name in
here
this is the type so something like that
now i'll show you the way this works so
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
come i'm going to save this
and notice that my content disappears
because i'm no longer outputting the
content
i'm going to open up my template parts
folder and i'm going to create a new
file in here
and it's going to be content dash
article dot php and then in here i'm
just going to simply
output just like i cut out the content
and save and now you can see it pops
back so the way this little function
works in our single
is it looks for the file name that you
have right here if you don't by the way
if you don't provide the second
parameter it just simply pulls up this
file
but if you do provide the second
parameter it looks for the hyphenated
version so content
dash article and that's the way this
works
so what this allows me to do is then i
can have another template part called
content dash
gallery if i have a file that's going to
be a gallery or something like that
so it allows you to kind of split up and
modularize all your
wordpress template files in another way
we're not going to be creating tons of
these i just wanted to demonstrate
sort of how this process works for uh
for this specific post
so uh that looks fine for this one uh
let's now go in and we're gonna
customize this article template
so if we come into here you can see
we're grabbing the content and that's
fine
but we also set up some tags we have a
featured image we set up a category
maybe i want the post date the post
author so there's a bunch of information
that's
typically called metadata or information
about the post that i may want to
display alongside
just the content so that's what we're
going to do next so let's go ahead and
set up all that metadata
you can recall what the post page looks
like i've pulled up here my template
file
so this is what a single post would look
like notice that we have the published
we have a few tags with some little
icons we have a link right here that
jumps us down to the comments section we
have comments with nested comments
and then of course we have a little
animation that happens in our sticky
header
and we have a featured image right here
and then everything
in here is going to be this is all the
post content right so all of this stuff
is coming from the post content so we
need to mock up all this extra stuff
so that's kind of how this page looks
like so let's jump back here to our code
and i'm going to open up that
specific uh template file here so that
is our post page our single post one
that we have mocked up here
and we're gonna grab some of this html
so we can paste it over into our php
template
so let's cruise down a little bit into
this section right here
okay so uh what we need
is we need this little
published three months ago we need that
we need the container
i guess we need a lot of stuff in here
so let's grab the container first
so we're going to grab this we're going
to grab this looks like that's mostly
all we need
so we'll copy that and we'll jump over
here to
our content article
and we'll paste that up there and then
of course we have this div right here we
need to close
because we need to close the div for the
container
let's kind of indent this back a little
bit
so we can kind of see how that's going
to look okay
so that should be okay so let's save
that and see what that's looking like
so that's much better so now we have our
published we have those tags and the
comments showing up
perfect so now we need to replace these
so they're not just
hard-coded i'll pull this over a little
bit and let's
line wrap again here oops i always hit
the wrong button there
one more time
okay so uh we need to replace these so
instead of saying published three months
ago of course this has to be the actual
date so here's we're going to pull out
information from the metadata of our
wordpress theme
so let's remove this published three
months ago and we'll replace this with
some
php tags and we're going to say
replace it with the function called the
underscore
date and now we'll save and refresh and
you can see that now
shows me the current date that this post
was published
now if you pass in parameters into this
function there's all sorts of
um you can format the date exactly how
you want using the php
date string formatters so you know we
can pass in
all sorts of things in here and format
that date exactly so i'm not really
going to worry about that right now
you can look up on the wordpress codex
there's codex excuse me
there's a lot of different ways you can
format the date just exactly how you
want so i could literally
have it say posted three months ago or
posted today or
or however you want that to be all right
now next we're gonna mess with these
tags these post tags so they're inside
of this span classes tag and then we
have an
icon and then we have the actual tag so
to make this a little bit easier to read
i'm just going to hit return here
on a single tag so we can kind of see
that and i'll move these comments down
as well
so they're each on their own line there
we go and i'm gonna actually
just reformat this a little bit so it's
easier to read
okay so we have this div and then inside
of this div we have these three sections
right
we have the date we have all of our tags
and then we have a link to the comments
so the next one we have to work on is
the tags so we're gonna
we're gonna leave that there so i can
reference the code and we're gonna add a
little bit of php code here
just tap this over and this is going to
be
for the tags okay so to add the tags in
here it's just simply called the tags
and you can see as i save that and
refresh i get my little tags output and
they automatically are anchor tags that
link to the tags
and then i can pass in a few parameters
into this function to customize it
so the first parameter is before the set
of tags
the second parameter is what's in
between each individual tag
and the third parameter is what comes
after the entire set of tags
so it's a little bit weird but basically
you can see here that
for us all of this comes before the tag
this comes after the tag so what we're
going to do here is we're going to copy
all of this code in fact i need to fix
these quotes really quick so they match
double quotes so all of this stuff is
going to come in that first parameter
the second parameter is what comes again
in the middle or in between each tag so
in between each tag
i need to close the span and then
also add all of this again because each
individual tag is wrapped by a span tag
so i'll paste all that right there and
then the last parameter
simply has to close out the list
again so whoops make sure that's a
closing span
okay so now if we save there we go so
you can see now each one of my
individual tags is wrapped
properly and showing up with my markup
okay so now i can delete this
hard-coded tag and save so that's
looking fine
now the next thing i need to do is add a
link here to the comments so we're going
to do that little section next what
we're going to do is delete our
hard-coded
number that says three comments and
we're going to replace that
with a little php or rather a wordpress
function that's called comments
count and what this does
um actually it's not comments count it's
comments number
we'll save that oops i forgot to close
my php right there
and you can see right now it says no
comments right so we're going to come
over here to our comments.php file which
is currently empty this is our template
file
and paste all the code for our comments
so all of that
is in our template file blog site
template
and we can come down here to our post
we've been working on and we'll come
down here to our comments section
and you can see there's quite a bit here
but it starts right here there's this
thing called comments wrapper
so i need to start right there and
basically copy all of the code
all the way down to where that wrapper
ends right there
and come over here to my comments.php
file so i'll close this down
and we'll close this down and we'll come
back to our
comments website and open it
comments.php and paste all right now
there is a lot of code in here that
we're going to end up deleting
because wordpress is going to provide
all this dynamically essentially all
this code
so what we can do now is
start replacing all of this so let's get
rid of my sidebar here
and we're gonna just going to start
piece by piece so again this is one of
those sections that if you can find an
existing theme that you like the
comments on
i really recommend like the 2020 thing
just copying their comments file
pasting it right into yours and be done
but just for the sake of this video
i will go over this really quick here
inside of this header two we're going to
be writing a little bit of logic
this is the comment reply title
so i'm going to open my php and close it
here
so here i can say if and then here's
where i'm going to do a little logic
here so i can say
if we don't have this is a php command
that's called
have comments in other words if this
post does not have
comments do what else
do something else in other words i can
change my title based on if there's
comments or not
so if i don't have comments i can simply
just
echo out something like
leave a comment okay we'll just
do that otherwise if i do have comments
i can echo out the number so i can say
get whoops i can say we'll just echo
something like i don't know
we'll say get i think it's get comments
count to get comments
count and then
concatenate that with comments okay
something like that so let's save and
refresh here and
before we get any further we need to add
that comments into our template
so that our template here can display
those comments as well so we'll come
back in here to
our content article and after
our content section we need to include
the
comments template so we're going to add
in the
it's called the comments it's literally
called comments template
template like so and save and refresh
and you can see sure enough now i'm
getting all
of my comments right here to appear
so that is looking fine
so basically what this does is this
comments template just pulls in that
common stop php file and it just
outputs it here directly now we can also
do some extra code here
i'm not going to do this but we could do
some checks in php to say
if we're allowing comments then output
the comments template or if there's no
comments if it's a single page if it's
an archive page don't show comments
right
we can do all sorts of logic to
determine when and when we do not want
to show the comments template
but for simplicity's sake i'll just
leave it turned on always
on this article page article template so
now that we have the comments being
output we can come back here to our
comments
and then actually start to
fix these guys up so
um let's see here now the next thing i
need to do is i need to do an
echo i forgot that because i'm not
seeing my title there we go so it says
leave a comment
and then i can say echo get the comments
count
okay so if i have comments it's gonna
output the number and then say comments
and if i don't have a comment it'll say
leave a comment and of course there is
no comments on this page even though i'm
showing some that's because they're hard
coded
okay so we have that now let's go ahead
and output each individual comment one
by one
and that's going to be done inside of
this comments intersection
so all of this code all of the divs that
belong to each individual comment and
their associated replies
wordpress is going to manage completely
so i can come in here and delete that
entire section of
code all the way down to
well looks like i have an error in my
some of my code because it's not showing
me the
there's comment one
so we can delete that
comment three we can delete
that and there we go okay so we just
have this little
comments wrapper then we're going to add
a command in here
that is going to output each individual
comment and that one is called wp
underscore list underscore comments
and this is very similar to the
wordpress menus that we did in the last
tutorial
where we can pass in a set of key values
in this
array to determine how those comments
are output so
there's all sorts of things here that
you can pass into this
i'm just going to quickly show you a
list of available options
the wordpress codex and you can see that
this function here the wordpress list
comments takes a whole bunch of
arguments
and here's all the arguments so you can
do a custom walker the maximum depth so
how many levels deep of replies you want
to show
your style so it defaults to unordered
lists
a callback function you can do the type
of comments so all
pings comments pingbacks how many
comments per page the size of the little
avatar image
anyway you can kind of see there's lots
of different options there so we're not
going to be doing that specific of
in our page just so you can see there's
several options
we're going to customize this back in
our code with just two parameters here
we're gonna do the avatar size one so
the avatar size we're gonna set to 120
pixels
and we're also going to set the style to
output as
divs instead of the default unordered
list
and we'll save that and make sure we
looks like we have an error there
unexpected
oh this has to be an empty array sorry
so i need to create an array
and then these properties go inside of
my array
okay there we go so of course there is
no comments right now
lastly we're going to set up the reply
section so we can actually add a comment
and then test all this out
so that's down right here you can see
that i've got this little div that says
respond and there's the little lever
reply so basically we're going to delete
this
and then replace that with the comment
form
so we'll just take this entire div
delete all that
and we're going to replace that with
the comment form now we are going to put
this inside of a conditional so we're
going to say
if comments open
and this is a function that checks to
see if this current
page or post is allowing comments so if
the comments are open or we're allowing
those
then we're going to output our form and
so
it's just a function called comment form
and just like the other stuff we've been
looking at it accepts
an array of parameters
so you can specify all sorts of
parameters on how your form displays the
classes and things like that
so we're going to just add a couple of
these for us
we're going to say the class for the
form is going to be set to
ours as section um
actually we don't even we don't actually
need to specify this so we're just going
to leave that blank for now
oops i got an error oh i always do that
we don't need a semicolon right there
there we go so that's looking correct
now
so the class form um
we'll go ahead and add one more so this
one's going to be the
title underscore reply before
so this is the title reply before text
and we're gonna do that as a header two
and it's gonna have the id
uh whoops header two height equals again
you don't need any of this this is just
a sample here reply dash
tile and it's going to have the class
of comment dash reply dash
title okay so that
is before and then the
title reply after
is going to be just closing that header
two out
h2 if i can type correctly
close that out and then save oops i have
another error in here what did i do this
time
oh forgot a comma right there
okay so there we go now i'm going to
back this up and i'm going to zoom back
out so we can kind of whoops wrong
zoom let's zoom back out our page here
back to a normal default level
so now you can kind of see it says leave
a reply
that's coming from you know our header
two over there
inside of that header two there's the
comment form
we have our name email website all this
stuff and then i can actually click the
post comment so it should
work correctly now so let's go ahead and
give it a test here so i'll say this
is a test comment name is follow andrew
email follow well guess we'll just do
hi hi website http clone slash
follow andrew.dev
um we don't need to save a cookie and
then i'll just say post comment
and we get an error okay so this is good
to know because we couldn't actually
test
this function until we had a comment in
there but it's saying hey there's an
uncut air
undefined function get comments count
on line 15. so
i think my comment actually posted
correctly but
uh i have the wrong code on the comments
count so let's scroll up and it's
right here online this line right here
where it says get
comments count it's telling me that that
function does not exist so i've got to
double check my note here and see if
that's
spelled correctly and sure enough it is
not
uh this is the exact same mistake i made
earlier it's not comments count it's get
comments number so if we save that
there we go now it's actually outputting
correctly
and sure enough there is my comment so
it's a waiting
approval because it hasn't been approved
yet but if you scroll up to the top
here we go it says zero comments because
it's not approved so let's just move
over and approve this so we can see this
working now
so let's jump here to the back end i'll
go to my comments
see how that test to comment did appear
there's my name and everything i'm just
gonna
go ahead and click approve of course you
can set your wordpress settings to auto
approve comments so you don't have to
manually approve them on your own
but let's jump back here to the front
end and refresh and it's working so
now it updated automatically to one
comment it says one comments down here
there's the comment i can of course
click the reply button
and add a reply so this is going to be a
nested
reply test at test.com
test.test.com oops i guess the name is
just test
and we'll post that comment let's go
back here and approve it
so let's refresh here and approve this
comment
jump back to our code and refresh
perfect so there's the initial comment
there is the nested comment and of
course
everything is now working properly
now in the sample page
you'll see that i actually think i
closed it down but my comments are
slightly formatted differently in the
sample template
and that's because the default wordpress
code that's being
output is not matching 100
to my style sheet that i have in my
comments
and the reason for that i'll just
explain that i'm not going to fix it
the reason for that is because i copied
again all of my comments code from the
wordpress
2020 theme so most of my css was copied
right from there
um and so all this comments belongs to
that
now in the wordpress 2020 theme when
they output their comments in the
comments.php file
so when they're down here on this little
comment form
um sorry not the comment form but in the
actual comment list right here in the
wordpress
list comments they are using a custom
walker
and so they're specifying additional
classes and things like that for every
single element
to be displayed and i'm not doing the
custom walker here i'm just doing the
default
so that's why my comments don't exactly
match my css
just wanted to quickly point that out
okay
so now we have everything working
properly we have our comments we have
replies nested comments everything's
fine of course if we had avatar
images set up via gravatar they would
show up here as the actual
avatar images and that's working fine
now
okay so that's pretty much it for the
post page let's move on now to
our archive page so the post archive so
this is a single post
now we're going to do another content
for the post archives
so if we open up our sidebar here we
have a
file called archive.php
so we can come into that file now the
archive php is going to be very similar
to the
single dot php so i'll just copy all
that
and come over here and paste
and then we'll remove the stuff we don't
need
um so what we're going to do is change
the template part so it's going to be
template parts instead of content
article i'm going to call this one
content
archive or something like this okay and
then we'll save
and then we'll come over here and create
a new template part so we'll
say template parts we'll duplicate this
file right here
i'm just going to i guess i'll do it
this way so we'll call this one the
content
dash archive.php
we'll come into the article highlight
everything and come into the archive and
paste everything okay so now let's just
remove stuff we don't need
so for example we don't want comments at
all on our blog our
archive page we don't need any of this
um header information so we don't need
tags we don't need all that stuff so we
can delete all that
so basically all we're going to have is
just the content
individual posts and pages that we'll be
creating here so we'll save that and
let's go ahead and now pull up an
archive page
now we don't have a way to get to an
in our menu so now's a good time to add
that
now there's a lot of different ways you
could do this in wordpress but what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to add a
new custom
item here to my menu called blog when
you click on that
it will take you to the archive page so
let's jump over here to our back end in
wordpress we're going to go to our
posts sorry not our posts we're going to
go to our
appearance menus and we're going to come
down in here and
add a new link here to our menu and this
one is going to be
a custom link
and
sorry not a custom link but rather a
custom page
and we need to go create the page first
i'm getting ahead of myself so we'll go
up here to pages
and we'll add a new page
i'm just going to simply call this one
blog i don't actually need to do any
content here i'm just going to say
publish
and publish okay now down under settings
and we can go back here to our reading
so we can have
our posts page be displayed on this
blog page okay so all this is basically
the archive page
and then i can hit save changes there we
go now we can go over to our appearance
and menus and then we can go
into our menu and we can come in here to
our pages
and we'll say view all we'll grab this
blog one and say
add to menu stick it right there now
remember we do need to give this guy our
classes so i'm going to give this guy
the
nav item class i could optionally give
it a
you know icon as well and we'll say save
okay so that's how you can add in a blog
so now if i refresh here you can see
i've got a new page called blog
when i click that it's going to open up
the archive template and right now you
can see it just says
test so let's come over here now
and set up my archive.php
template now because we have
our setting reading section set up to
show
that our home page displays
the static page set to this one and our
post page is set to our blog page
our archive.php template is
not going to show the blog post archives
the archive.php template only shows
things like category archives template
archives
tag archives custom post type archives
date based post archives things like
that
so our index.php file is actually going
to be the file that's used for our blog
posts archives so what we can do is we
can just come in here and copy this
exact
archive because essentially all of our
archive pages are going to be very
similar
so i'll just copy this come over here to
the index.php page
and now we'll go ahead and paste and
save
okay now you can see that
this is showing up as we expect
so it's showing me right some things
happening here
and that's all great and wonderful now
if we come into our
template part here for our content
dash archive i don't want to output the
content
on my blog archive page in other words i
don't want the full blog post to appear
on the archive page i only want the
excerpt
so i can say the excerpt and save
and then i'm only going to get the post
excerpts for those individual posts
so here's where i need to jump back to
wordpress and now i need to create a
whole bunch of posts
so go ahead and if you don't have this
pause the video create i don't know 10
or 12 posts probably at least 10 because
i think the default is 10 per page
so create 12 posts i'll go ahead and do
that make sure to give each post a
featured image if you can
and then go ahead and start the video
back up
okay so i have here you can see a bunch
of different posts
now they're all displaying the excerpt
because that's how i'm currently
displaying here
and now we need to go back to our posts
page
from our template so our not our post
page our
archive page and see how we have this
mocked up
so down here in this section you can see
that
we have our content then we have our
container
and then we have our post
so this little post right here
is repeated over and over and over so
there's one two three right for every
single post
archive and excerpt that's where that's
repeated so i'm going to copy this code
and we're going to jump back over here
to our content dash
archive and we are simply going to
paste that into here okay so
now we can begin to let me just back
that up flesh this out
so the section right here this is the
actual where this div class
is content that's my excerpt so i'll
delete
all the lorem ipsum let me wrap lines
here again
and we'll replace that with the excerpt
okay then we'll save that there we go
so that's the post excerpt coming in
here now this section up here this
header three is the post
title so i'll delete that and i'll
replace
this
with the post title which is
whoops the title like so
and save that okay perfect now i get all
of my post
titles in there and that looks great
uh the date right here is the
the date just like we did on the other
one
and we'll save that so there's the date
and then we have
this thing that says a five minute read
now there's currently no way we're going
to be able to implement that
there are some plugins actually that
will calculate the length of the text in
your post
and then automatically give a suggested
reading time based on average reading
words
so we're just going to kind of leave
that blank for now we actually could set
this up
with a custom field so perhaps we could
do that
in a future tutorial where we do a
little bit more advanced things but
we'll just leave it
for right now we're actually probably
just going to leave it off so i'll come
into this time here
and we'll just delete the time we're not
going to worry about that
and then we have the comments uh how
many comments
so this was the i forgot this one
already we just probably did it
uh it's not comments count it's comments
number i always
say count and save that so you can see
no comments
no comments and down here on one of our
posts there's the one that has two
comments
so that one we added our comments on
there's three comments on that one
okay so that is looking just fine like
so and i think that's about
all we need for this right now so the
last thing is we need this little read
more link
this should link into the actual post so
we need to make it so that our read more
actually goes into the post so all we
need to do is replace this url here
that's hard-coded
with uh what's known as the permalink
and then the permalink
is a term that references the actual
permanent url for the
page you're requesting so we just simply
type the permalink and we save
now watch over here as i hover over the
read more link down here at the bottom
you'll be able to see right here this
one's going to
page 45 this one's going to post rather
this is going to post 41. so now if i
click on these
this will take me into that individual
post
and this one will take me into that
individual post
individual post okay
perfect so now we have the permalinks we
have the excerpts and the only thing
we're missing now is our featured
thumbnail image
and we'll do that with uh getting the
post thumbnail
we'll do that up here in our image tag
now just to kind of show you there's two
ways you can do this the first the easy
way is just calling the post
thumbnail like this and saving um
[Music]
oops i forgot an l right there and you
can see it outputs a thumbnail
now if i inspect this element the
problem with this
is that again wordpress creates all
these classes
on it by itself and i don't really want
that i have my own image with my own set
of classes
so really all i need is the url i want
the source
so we can replace this with the thumb
url
whoops and save and refresh and you can
see that will just return me with the
absolute path to that thumbnail image
which is what i want so now we can just
grab this and
replace that here in
our source so we'll delete the source
php replace that and save
and now we can delete this little code
up here
and we should be getting that
source to appear there so let's double
check so image sure enough there is the
image so that should work fine
now on my tablet view i actually have
those hidden so i need to actually
resize this
up and there we go so on desktop they're
appearing
on tablet i have those disappearing
right at that breakpoint
and then we get down to our mobile view
um
they're gonna they're gonna reappear so
or they're also hidden on mobile so
you're only make sure you resize
and get up to your desktop view to be
able to see those thumbnails
now one important thing to note here is
that if you just use the post
thumbnail by default it actually pulls
back the url for the full size
image which is a problem so for example
if you look right here and i refresh
this
page here so on this last one here if i
say view
image notice it's pulling in a very very
large image
it's just scaling it down teeny tiny
which we definitely do not want for our
archives page
so with this function here the post
thumbnail url
you can pass in a string as
the parameter in here to specify which
size
so in my case i want to specify the
thumbnail size
now remember those sizes are coming here
from your settings
media so there's my thumbnail medium and
large
so i want the width 150 by 150 so now
when i update that and save here
now let's come in here and refresh this
whoops
notice now when i click on this and say
view image it's giving me the proper
thumbnail image so definitely double
check that
a little got you there whenever you're
working with pulling in thumbnails
okay so that's pretty much it for our
archive page so we have
all of our posts now on our blog so if
we click on blog
we get our blog archive page we get all
of these
uh fancy titles here and
that's pretty much pretty much it
so uh what we need to do next is we need
to add
in our pagination links so down here at
the bottom we have some links where if
we can go to page two page three
etc etc so we'll just add in the
pagination links
down below now one important thing we
need to do first is we need to come over
to your back end
and go to your settings and reading
and i'm just going to set my blog shows
at most
four posts this way you can actually see
the pagination links because by default
there's
10 per page so set that to 4 set that to
hit save changes then when we come back
here and refresh
we'll actually only be able to see four
posts then we'll be able to see the next
links when we update those so in order
to do this all we have to do is come
into our
index.php file right after our
loop here and we're going to add in
these
uh pagination links
so uh the code here we'll just open and
close some php tags
and it is called the
uh posts pagination
and then we save there and that's pretty
much it so this will automatically
output your previous
next link so i can click on page one i
can click on page two
and you get the previous and next links
in the current page depending on where
you're currently at
so that's pretty much all there is to
that
there um are a few arguments you can
pass into this post-pagination
link but we're not going to cover those
you can go ahead and look at the
codecs to see all the available
arguments
so that should pretty much do it for the
pagination so let's kind of
see where we're at right now we have our
blog
archive page that works fine we have our
pagination that's letting us go from
page to page
you can of course clean this tile up and
break things around as you want in your
css sheet
we have our single pages
we don't have our single pages we have
our single blog posts
done oh whoops we need to make that a
link
so uh we need to make this title be a
link just like we have the read more
link it'd be nice if we could also click
on the title to take us
into the blog post so let's go ahead and
make that little change really quick
so we'll come in here to our content
archive
and we're just going to basically copy
here this permalink
code right there and we'll
introduce that into the title so we'll
create an anchor tag
and we will say href
equals paste that in there
and then close the anchor tag afterwards
whoops close the anchor tag okay now we
should be able to click the post title
perfect and that works as well as
clicking the read more so either one of
those will take us
into the actual page or post
okay now the next step we're going to do
is be building out our page so we have
our posts but we don't
have the template here for the page so
this will be fairly simple as it's
pretty much the same as the other ones
so we're going to come in here to the
one called content article let's copy
all the code right here
let's create a new template part so
we're going to say new file
and we will call this one content
content
if i can spell this right page.php
let's just go ahead and do a quick paste
right here and
now this one is not going to have
comments so i don't have comments on
pages so i can delete the comments
template
from this one i'm not going to have tags
so i can delete the tags
i'm not going to have the date basically
i'm not going to have anything inside of
the header so i'm just going to delete
the entire header
all we really have is just the content
for this guy okay so now we can come
down to
our page.php and just like we have in
here
our single.php we can copy all of this
from
single.php and paste it into
page.php remember page.php is the
template file responsible
for single pages so let's copy that
we'll replace this instead of article
this is going to be what we call that
page
template part page save and that should
be it
so now we have our individual pages so
there's our sap
page there's the about page there's the
contact page
and they're all working exactly as they
should so
again pages are very similar to articles
and the blog single ones are a little
bit different because they help us
extra information up there as well as
comments down below
so that pretty much does it for
the pages
so the last thing we need to do before
this entire tutorial is completely
finalized is add just a couple of extra
things
with widgets so for example if i wanted
to have this
area over here be user customizable
so they can drag and drop their own
things in here and we need to set up
what are known as
widgets same thing with the footer maybe
i want them to be able to customize the
footer
so we're going to add several different
widget areas that the user is then able
to drag and drop
content from the wordpress admin widget
interface
so let's go ahead and do that those are
done in the
let's see if we can cruise up here to
the top here and
minimize some of these things so that's
going to be done inside of our
templates.pa hernander templates our
functions.php file
where we're going to be adding some more
features here
and the feature we're going to be
looking at is what is known as register
sidebars so we're going to allow various
sidebars which are basically little
minute widget areas little mini widget
areas in order to add stuff so let's do
that right now
i'll just move down here to the bottom
in order to
add these guys in so we're going to
create a new function here
and this is just going to be called the
follow andrew
and we'll call this widget areas
and inside of this function we're going
to call a command that's called
register sidebar whoops register
sidebar and inside of here
this function takes an array
just like we've seen with many of the
other functions an array of arguments
and whoops just kind of format this a
little prettier
and the array is a bunch of the defaults
on how this
sidebar is set up so the first thing
we're going to do is there's an
option in here called before
title so before title
and right now i'm just going to leave
that blank for now
i'll show you what this does in a minute
when we actually set them up in our
actual
theme here there's one called after
title and i'll leave that one blank
there's one called before widget
so this is before widget
and i'll leave that blank and then
there's another one called after widget
and i'll leave that one blank and then
there is
um so all of these are
options that are in the first parameter
for the register sidebar so this is
parameter one as an array of these
options okay
comma and then parameter two
is another array
and this is another set of options here
so in the second parameter you have
things like the name of the widget
so i'm only going to create two widget
areas one's going to be in my sidebar
one's going to be in my footer
whoops so this one here will be called
my
sidebar area for lack of a better name
and the next one will give this guy an
id
and i'll just call this sidebar dash one
that's the css id it will become and
then we can
optionally give this guy a description
so i'll just call this the
sidebar a widget area
okay so that's pretty much everything we
need
for the second uh parameter so let's now
go ahead and come down here
before we get too much code let's make
sure we can get this guy to load
so we're going to hook this guy into
another action
just like we've done many times we're
going to say add action
and it's going to be on the widgets init
action and we'll copy and paste our
function name
so when the widgets are initialized our
custom function will be
executed causing us to register this new
sidebar
so we'll save that oops i missed the
semicolon there
looks like i have another issue here
parse air unexpected
oh right here whoops these are all
supposed to be commas
comma comma comma comma because those
are array arguments
okay there we go so i don't get any
errors so now let's jump back to the
back end of wordpress
and let's go over here to our
appearance and we're going to come over
here down to
widgets and there we go so you can see i
had now have a new
thing in here called sidebar one and
i can drop let's just for example let's
drop in
tags so there should be a tag cloud here
so i'm gonna grab tags i'm gonna drop it
in
and notice i can give this guy a title
so i'll just call this tag cloud
and this title here tag cloud
is what this before title and after
title are used for so for example i
could wrap this with a header 2 tag
and basically wordpress will put that
title inside of a header to tag or
whatever you want to do
so i'll just leave that and save to show
this as an example
now right now i'm not seeing that in my
sidebar at all
because all i've done is register the
sidebar i'm not actually outputting the
sidebar in my sidebar yet
so what we need to do next is we need to
then come into our
template files and output that in our
theme now our sidebar is in our section
we called
header so i'll come over here to my
header.php file
and we will come down to the sort of
right here's that header tag and
everything inside of that header tag
is what's displayed in this area
so we'll come clear down here at the
bottom so one quick example is i could
have
all of these social icons be inside of a
widget so people can then customize them
from the back end
so we'll probably do that here in a
second but after this
i'll see what's this div tag for that's
the navigation so after this
nav tag
i'll actually do it inside here so right
after this div so here's where we're
going to output
uh that sidebar
so we open some php tags we close some
php tags
and then we're going to do the command
is called dynamic
dynamic if i can spell that correctly
sidebar and you pass as a parameter to
this
the id of your sidebar so in my
case this would be back in my functions
this is the id right here so i'm going
to say sidebar dash
one so we'll come back in here to my
header and we'll pass in that sidebar
one
and save and sure enough you can see now
there's all of these tags in the tag
cloud now it's a little bit goofy here
because i'm
outputting this inside of my
header area which is a little bit weird
right
inside of my navigation tag
oh have somehow crashed oh
it crashed let's reopen this see if we
can get it back open alive for us
vs code crash dummy so i could move this
maybe outside of my nav
but still inside of my header but of
course you're going to get some
my template wasn't built initially to
have this in place so i'm going to have
some issues here of course
but that's how that works so you can add
in your little
templates areas as you need
so uh let's now instead of having this
guy just be a random tag cloud i'm gonna
make this guy
be this unordered list here
so i'll cut this and i'll paste this
right here
and remember this guy has it's an
unordered list
and it has these classes on it so what i
could do
is i could come back here to my
functions file
and before widget and after widget
i can add in that code so i'm going to
copy and paste that
got too many files open here again i
gotta start closing some of these
so i can just easily go back and forth
here
just close all these down really quick
this will just take me a second
all right so i'm going to copy this
unordered list
basically all of that and that's going
to go in my before widget
and then after the widget i'm just going
to close the unordered list
and then i don't really want anything
output for the title before and after
the title
and we'll save that and refresh
here whoops i need to go take my tag
cloud out so we'll go back to the back
end
so having that tag cloud really doesn't
make sense so i'm going to delete the
tag cloud
and just replace it instead with an
arbitrary text field
i'm not going to have a title but what
this allows me to do is then i can come
in here
and in my text area i can just copy and
paste
all of the code for that
in my whoops in my header file right
here
so all of the code that belongs
basically to all of those little
unordered lists so i'm going to copy all
that unordered list cut it out rather
and i'll paste it inside of the dynamic
sidebar instead
so i can come in here and just paste all
that hit save
and then when i come over here and
refresh
we should still see all those links but
now they're editable from the user's
front end so they can come in here right
to the backend and if they don't have
twitter or don't have github
so let's just take one of these a little
hard to kind of see where they start and
begin let's just take this
github one and delete to right
there and then save and now
of course github disappears right so
they can edit that from the wordpress
admin
and really you can put anything inside
of widget areas there's all sorts any of
these things you can drag inside of a
widget area
so that's kind of how they work so i've
got that one little sidebar one let's
just add one more
to the footer so we'll come over here
and we'll come back to our functions and
i'm just going to copy
all of this register sidebar code right
here
and just paste it because we're going to
register one more this one's going to be
called the
footer area and we'll call it footer
dash one
we'll call this the footer widget area
save come back to our
back end to make sure that's being
registered properly so if we refresh we
should see our sidebar too
and there it is over there so now we
have our second sidebar
uh registered and that
is going to be um
actually i'm not sure why the name
parameter isn't working
so the name should say
instead of saying sidebar dash one
sidebar two side by one i should say
footer area
sidebar area so i must have something
incorrect here let me just double check
my notes
i did have something wrong here so the
problem is there's not
two separate um there's not two separate
parameters here actually there's just
one big array
i was going off notes where i'm actually
merging two arrays together so that's
why i got confused when i was looking at
my notes
so it's just one big array for all the
properties here so all i can do is just
simply
delete that to not create two arrays
just have one single array
of all of those properties and now when
i jump back here and refresh
that should update there we go okay so
now that's looking correct right it says
sidebar area there's my description
this one says footer there's my
description so let's just drag and drop
into the footer
uh maybe some meta data i don't know
we'll just drop this one in here just to
showcase this
and it's saved there so now i can come
into my footer
and just like before in my header where
you add the dynamic sidebar i'll copy
that
i'll open up my footer.php
and inside of the footer area
i'll paste that dynamic sidebar and this
one is called
footer dash one and save
so now when we refresh over here
in our uh theme here
did i call that footer dash one i
actually don't see it appearing
let's just inspect let's double check
and make sure we have some code saved
there
um test let's save
refresh oh there we go just must not
have that
refreshed so there's all the metadata
right where you can log in and see all
these different things that wordpress
adds
but now that that's in place i can put
whatever i want in there right
maybe i want to put a link to
[Music]
oh i don't know maybe i want my archives
down there so we can call this the
archives and save and now when i refresh
i get a link to all my archives i can
click on an archive and of course i'm
going to get all the blog archives from
march
so that uh that's how you do widget
areas
inside of wordpress to be able to
customize those
so that pretty much brings us to the
final piece of this
custom wordpress theme tutorial we just
have a couple little things to finish up
here and one is the 404 template
now a 404 template is the page that
shows
when uh somebody navigates to a link
that's broken or something on your
website
so what we can do is i'm just going to
come in here to my
index and i'm just going to highlight
all this and come over here to the 404
template
and paste and instead of having there's
obviously no
posts on the 404 so i can just go ahead
and delete this
loop and i'm going to go ahead and get
rid of this navigation
and then i'm just going to fill in this
with the header one that says page not
found
and then just save this now you can come
over here now in my little preview here
i've just
added the page id that doesn't exist
right i can say 555 and hit return
and so i get myself a nice little not
found
now some things that wordpress
developers do is on the not found page
they'll also query the database and
maybe pull out a bunch of recent posts
so the user still has something to look
at and click
what i'm going to do is i'm going to add
the search form
so we can come over here and let's go
ahead and add the search form
code for that is just it's fairly simple
here so i'll open up my php tags and
i'll go ahead and close these
and it's called get the search
form actually it's not get the it's just
git search
sorry get search form
like that and you can see it
automatically gives me a search and now
i can search for a page i can say
test and hit search and this will then
take me to my search page
now you'll notice that my search results
page is blank because i haven't yet
set that up so let's go ahead and set
that up next
now that of course is down over here in
my file called
search so let's come over here and this
is going to behave very similarly to an
archive page so i'm going to come to my
archive page and just
copy all of this and come over here to
my search page and just paste
and let's just save that and you can see
that's going ahead and pull up
my archive page so anything that has
test
right is going to show up here so let's
do a different type of search here
i'll just click back here i think i
added a bunch of tags with
um i can't remember with cool c-o-o-l
so if i search for that nope it's not
searching my uh
tags i don't even know i can't remember
what i'm on post pages we're called
let's come over here and look let's go
to our um blog
and let's see so
so if i type in the word fancy okay so
that post has fancy in the tile
so if i come over here to let's actually
go back to the 404
um so we'll just go to a page
here and then type in one that doesn't
exist five five five five
let's search for the word fancy hit
return and you can see sure enough it's
giving me the result from the
fancy post pulling up on this search
page
so that's really all i need to do there
i of course could come into the header
and maybe i don't want to get the main
header i could change this to say like
you know search results or something
like that i can modify those
however i need i'm just going to leave
that of course you can modify this
template as you need
but that's how you get the search now
something that i might want to allow is
that my
visitors can search from any page so
it's common right to have maybe a
section inside of here in your header
with a search form
i'm just going to add one down here in
the footer so that the search is
available on every single page
so i can come over here to my footer
there's a couple of ways you can do this
you can use the exact same thing like we
did
on the 404 page and hard code in a
search form so i can just copy this
paste that down into my footer area and
then i'll have that search form
however you can also do it with widgets
so i'll show you because we already set
up a widget area down here
i'll go ahead and show you how you can
set that up i'm logged into the back end
so i'm going to come down here again to
my appearance then over to
widgets and i already have my footer
area widget you can see that has that
archives
and you can see from the available
widgets over here in the left hand
column there's one called
search and we'll search all of the posts
so i can just drag this over here and
drop this
in my area here and just say search
go ahead and click on save and now when
i switch back over to my front end and
refresh
you'll see the search form appears right
here so now i can come in here and say
test
and click search and i can just go ahead
and search to my heart's content of
course the formatting here isn't all
formatted because my footer isn't set up
to have
that all formatted nice and pretty it'd
be nice if i set up maybe three separate
areas in my footer like three columns
where i could have three separate widget
areas
but again you can do that all easily
with what we've learned here in this
series here in this lengthy wordpress
we could really go on for hours and
hours and hours there's so many things
in wordpress and so many functions
we could make this a hundred hour
tutorial literally to cover everything
that is inside of wordpress
but this should give you enough to get
completely started with building your
own
wordpress theme and converting an
existing html thing
theme over into a wordpress theme
a few things that we didn't cover i'll
just kind of mention that are
somewhat popular inside of themes one is
a thing called custom post
types so you can add those in your
custom theme what that allows for you to
do
is have your own post types so instead
of just having posts
and pages you could have one called
car reviews and you could have one
called videos
and you can add a new car review so you
can basically customize any of those
main hierarchical categories
inside of there there's another thing
called
custom fields which allows you to add
custom fields to your posts or pages
so an example of that i mentioned
earlier is i could come into a post and
say
add new and maybe i wanted to have maybe
this is a recipe
and i wanted to have recipe ingredients
and i want to be able to say this one's
five minutes this one's seven minutes or
something like that
you can add custom fields to be able to
have like a duration of ten minutes
or or like we used before an article
read time i could say the read time is
six minutes or something like that
and then i can output those custom
fields inside of wordpress as well
so again you can completely customize
your theme and go as far as you want
uh there's also many many plugins that
do all the stuff we've been doing
manually as well so search the plugin
repository as well
i hope you've learned something i hope
this gives you a great starting point to
be building your custom wordpress theme
ours is pretty much complete here with
taking our
uh page and turning it all into a cms
built on wordpress so all the content is
now managed there
i hope you've liked it uh don't forget
to like and subscribe
and share this content with others so
they can benefit as well
and we will see you in the next one